welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
[Music]
Halloween earlier in the month we ran up
all to see what you guys wanted as a
Halloween holiday breakdown and no
surprises that Carpenter's classic
wanted out throughout this video we're
going to be going through the movie
scene by scene to talk about all the
hidden details and things you might have
missed in it now you might be able to
hear that I've got got a bit of a cold
but it adds some atmosphere to the video
doesn't it so yeah if you if you enjoy
it please hit that thumbs up button and
I'll I'll try to catch more viruses to
keep the mood of the videos right now
Halloween is arguably one of the most
influential films of all time though it
didn't invent the slasher genre it
certainly feels like one of its most
important properties with it Paving the
way for several films to come now the
genre really began with both peeping Tom
and psycho dropping during 1960 however
the genre really hit its peak during
1974 to 1984 with it often being
referred to as the Golden Age of slasher
films Texas Chainsaw Massac dropped in
1974 with it being followed by black
Christmas and then later Halloween after
that we got Friday the 13th and then
Nightmare on Elm Street which both
released during the 80s still though
Halloween might have the biggest Legacy
out of them with there being several
reboots and recalls building off the
back of it I think there's just
something about Michael Myers that's
remain stantly iconic and he's a
character who's still as terrifying
today as he was back in the 70s now
Carpenter was approached with the idea
for the film back in 1976 during
screenings of Assault on Precinct 13
producers Ann yablin and Mustafa aad
went to him with the idea of a killer
that specifically targeted babysitters
there were rumors that the movie was
originally going to be called the
babysitter murders but this since has
been debunked specifically by ylin the
film was always going to take place on
Halloween night which Carpenter loved is
that had never been a theme in a film
looking back it's crazy that it took
someone so long to set a horror on that
night and it's pretty wild that this was
the first to fully embrace the tradition
there have been some that th carbiner
somewhat took the idea from Black
Christmas director Bob Clark after he'd
apparently asked him for ideas on a
sequel to that film Clark said he wasn't
planning on one but he thought that the
killer could escape from a mental
institution after being caught and then
go back and do it all again he said he
would have called it Halloween but Clark
shut down the idea that Carpenter had
copied him because he was approached by
outsiders with the idea and it was just
one big coincidence now Carpenter agreed
to do it and he signed on with the
stipulation that he'd get full creative
control paid $10,000 yes
$10,000 he would write direct and score
the film alongside his then girlfriend
Deborah Hill to be fair it was the 70s
and Kow was still looking to build an
name for himself but to do all that and
have the massive hit that it was woo
need some roties off the back of that
now either way they started crafting the
screenplay which in total took 10 days
to write pulling from the Celtic
traditions of Halloween it would center
around the idea of evil and how in the
end you couldn't actually kill it
looking at the festival of Sam ha this
was when all the souls of the Dead would
break out to wreck havoc on the living
which inspired Michael's big return to
town stating that they'd show the adult
version of the most evil kid that ever
lived they then began building up to
what we got hadn't field was pitched as
a town with a dark secret and it was
supposed to be home of one of the most
horrifying events on Earth though that
evil had been locked up it had now come
back and it's a tale that transformed
Cinema ooh some really cool with it
called now they also looked at the idea
of haunted houses which the Mayers home
ends up becoming saying that every town
has its own Haunted House story this
would be relatable worldwide and give
the film Mass Appeal I'm sure all of you
growing up you you remember there being
like a house down the lane where
somebody died in a or something and he
used to walk past it and kind of think
oh I'm not I'm not going in there that's
what Carpenter described the tale as
with Mayers almost being an embodiment
of a curse put upon the town Deborah
Hill herself was also a babysitter once
and she named haddenfield after her home
and haddenfield New Jersey Warren County
on the police badge came from
Carpenter's home Bowling Green with even
the name Lorie stro being one of
Carpenter's old girlfriends Michael
Myers was the name of a British producer
and Carpenter pulled some names from his
favorite Hitchcock films as well Tommy
Dy was named after Thomas Dy from rear
window and Samuel Lumis was a odd to Sam
Lumis in Psycho as we know Jamie Lee
Curtis was also the daughter of Janet
Lee and I love going back and seeing all
these little nods of the creative team's
life laid throughout the movie now when
it comes to Casting both Peter Cushing
and Christopher Lee were approached for
Dr Lumis the latter admitted turning it
down was the biggest mistake of his
career with Donald Pleasants of course
being the one who got the role the film
started off his in carbon his friendship
and he then gone to star in several of
other carpenter films he was the highest
paid getting $220,000 with Jam Lee
Curtis receiving $8,000 Nick Castle who
played Michael got $25 a day which is
crazy when you look back at it now if
you been keeping up with the channel
then you'll know we did lots of videos
about John carpent as the thing and a
huge shout out to David the ridge 5748
for pointing out on our last video that
nit Castle's actually in it there's a
shadow that's meant to make the audience
wonder if Palmer or norus got infected
did and this actually belongs to none
other than Nick now as I'm sure you know
this is like a massive piece of movie
trivia probably up there with the the
Back to the Future signs Twin Pine more
thing and but as I'm sure you know they
ended up getting a mask of Captain Kirk
to base Michael's look around stories
been told it as many times as this
movie's been covered but you guys voted
for it so you're going to get it now but
the production team obviously didn't
have much money so they grabbed it from
a costume store for $1.98 they painted
it white alter the hair and the eyes
were also widen and too which gives him
this iconic ghostlike look one day I I
kind of hope William Shatner goes in a
killing spree and he ends up wearing an
Austin Powers mask like baby driver but
we can only dream now many of the actors
they also had to wear their own clothes
with the cars being rented from a local
dealer the original idea for the film
was also going to take place over a
number of days but they cut this down
because different days might need
different costume changes shut over 20
days it was filmed on location at a
cemetery in Sierra
Garfield Elementary and an abandoned
house loaned out by the church the
Street Scenes were also shot out in
Hollywood with palm trees on the street
being viewable down certain streets the
cars also have California license plates
however they were often kept out of the
way to give the idea this was a
Midwestern Town Robert England also
revealed that he worked on the film too
and he said he often swept up the leaves
after a scene to then go and use them
and others yeah no you it's so funny I
actually uh had a roommate uh back when
they did the original Halloween the John
Carpenter one and he I wasn't working he
conned me into going to Pasadena one day
with garbage bags full of Dead Leaves
and we were working on the set of the
original Halloween movie The Dead Leaves
around so it looked like Autumn so it
looked like fall back in the midwest wow
You' had many lives in this I love it
lastly local families were asked to
dress their kids of Patrick or treat and
though it was filmed in Spring you would
swear it was October and the movie is
laced with lots of subliminal imagery
and this comes down right even to the
poster uses un rded a couple of years
back spot the hand holding the knife
actually has a hidden detail in it
rotating it more so it's sideways and
looking directly at it we can see that
there's a set of eyes nose and a mouth
on top of this we also have the blade
itself which is apparently carrying the
reflection of a screaming woman now from
here we C to the unforgettable title
sequence in which we see a Jacko Lantern
burning away in the dark originally
there was going to be a long shot of the
sidewalk which would end with a
Halloween mask on the floor but instead
they went with this which ended up
becoming iconic it's here that we of
course first hear the inFamous theme
tune which is also played in a five4
time signature which is something
Carpenter learned from his dad it can't
be overstated how much the music makes
this movie and Carpenter actually
screamed the film to an executive
without using the backing track they
said they didn't find it scary at all
but upon seeing it with a score they
completely changed their mind analysts
have also pointed out the nose on the
pumpkin looks like a knife with the slit
coming down from it being sort of like a
handle they've also said that the two
eyes somewhat resemble two heads with
the one on the left being a victim and
the right being a killer either way
shout outs to sees well for pointing out
that we zoom in on the pumpkin's eye and
that's later the same one that Michael
gets stabbed in the lights go out
showing just those two things and to me
it creates more of a silhouette at this
point now from here we C to Halloween
night in in 1963 and we see through
Michael's eyes the murder of his sister
one thing I've not seen in other
breakdowns is that this was actually
inspired by the opening shut of aen
Wells movie Touch of Evil that was one
long take and both give this sort of
veristic feeling to what's going on now
putting us in the point of view of a
killer is something that's been done to
death in other movies but at this point
it was relatively new the only other one
I can think of is the opening of Jaws
but this moment stopped off with a big
reveal at the end that of course reveals
it's a child who's carried out this
horrific act and yeah it's it's easily
one of the most memorable scenes of all
time now in it we see Michael
approaching the house and watching his
sister and her boyfriend start to get it
on at this point you have no idea this
is actually Michael's house and I think
there's a lot of things going on here
that perhaps spell out what's happening
with him psychologically Michael was
exposed his sex at a young age and in
many ways his child Minds unable to
comprehend it he somewhat tries to mimic
what he sees her boyfriend doing but he
just can't seem to quite grasp exactly
what this is now you might notice that
her boyfriend's the one who puts on the
clown mask and later he puts us on
before carrying out the attack after he
finishes the ACT he leaves just like he
did and is following in his footsteps in
many ways also nice little detail I
noticed here is that Judith says her
parents are going to be home at 10:
after Michael kills her the clock then
shines which is followed by the parents
arriving at the house well so whole
scene is like 2 minutes long so hey man
was a pump and dump and he just headed
out of there anyway don't want to
analyze that too much but Michael grabs
a knife out the drawer and at this point
the camera goes a little blurry due to
kids being limited to only film a
certain length they didn't want to waste
his time in case they needed to do the
scene again thus that's actually Deborah
hell's hand with her also doing the
stabbing upstairs and basically these
point of view shots now I know the
knife's also seen as a phallic symbol
with this being what he uses to kill his
sister however however phallicism gets
switched when Lori stabs him in the neck
and Carpenter talked about this on the
commentary he said for years it's often
been interpreted that because L's the
Virgin that this is the symbolic reason
that she survives in the end however
Carpenter said critics completely missed
the point and that she's actually the
most sexually uptight and frustrated one
she's the one who survives but not
because she's a virgin but because that
energy ends up coming out he said that
she uses a phallic symbol to stab him
which is somewhat a reversal of this
now I'm someone I know I talk about in
these breakdowns a lot but it's cuz
people mention it in commentaries and
stuff but I don't know if I if I don't
have that Freud ins side of film making
to me but yeah I just totally miss this
stuff normally but if you want to say a
dick it's a bloody dick now there is
definitely this idea of sex lce
throughout the film now and even in
these early moments we see the themes of
it being created SE will pointed out
that just before Michael attacks her he
stares at the bed sheets and bed sheets
play a big part in a lot of scenes with
him when Lori looks out the window
Michael's standing behind them and later
on he wears one when going to kill Linda
during the stabbing Michael also stares
at the knife almost like his focus is on
that rather than the killing it's clear
that he never gets over this Obsession
that he has here and he later makes a
shrine for his sister by using Annie's
body also if you look at the wallpaper
here it's different to what we see later
when Lumis visits the home I feel like
they changed it when trying to sell the
house but there's just something off
about the entire place now outside he's
then unmasked with this carrying a lot
of meaning to it as well Carpenter said
that he wanted Michael to look Angelic
rather than being a monster or appearing
evil I've always kind of likened this to
how we imagine Lucifer with him very
much being a fallen angel figure
Michael's meant to just be the shape
that evil takes with the shape even
being what He's listed at in the credits
the name in mask somewhat dehumanizes
him and he's rather just a form of evil
instead of necessarily being a person
and from here we C to October 30th 1978
and watched Dr Lumis and nurse Marian
driving through the night Marian is
potentially another nut tosyo with
Marion being the name of Janet Le's
character she was someone who was dating
Sam Lumis and again it could be
Carpenter pulling from that now
Pleasants was attracted to this role
because he saw it as being something
that he hadn't had a chance to do before
throughout his career he' mainly played
villains but he felt like this could be
a vanh heling esque figure the name
Samuel could also will be a reference to
the two subjects in the classroom with
us getting a debate about fate Kain
wrote that fate was somehow related only
to religion where Samuels felt that well
fate was like a natural element like
earth air Fire and Water Samuels was
constantly trying to warn about fate
just in the same way Samuel Lumis was
warning about Michael in this context
fate is seen as being death with Destiny
catching up to people that Samuels was
trying to warn death is of course
personified by Michael so we have these
IDE of fate and warning in these two
characters in Samuel's writing fate is
immovable like a mountain it stands
where man passes away fate never changes
by that logic evil could be one too with
a taking the shape of Michael Myers my
has also referred to it instead of him
with us learning Lumis has tried to keep
him locked up you mean you actually
never want him to get out never
never now as they approach we get
further foreshadowing to the idea of
sheets with the escaped inmates being on
the lawn the idea of an escaped insane
asylum inmate also prayed on Fier at the
time with there being the idea Killers
could break free from them Michael ends
up then smashing the car window like
it's a like button and I'm sure you know
this but just in case you don't you
actually can see a wrench on his hand
painted pink so that he could break the
glass easier now heading out we see the
tail light vanish in the dark showing
that Evil's now been Unleashed let's be
honest yeah the film's pretty badly lit
but I actually think that this
limitation helps with the scares this
was purely down to the budget which was
so low they actually couldn't afford to
buy expensive light I do remember back
in the day trying to watch this on VHS
and if you did it as well I'm sure you
know it was almost impossible to see
what was going on these days we have HDR
and Dolby Vision so the details are
easier to refine with these newer
Technologies still though just the
darkness that's part of these scenes it
kind of adds to what could be hiding out
amongst it it also helps to contrast
with how safe it feels in the day and
the night shots feel even darker because
of how bright they are in them we end up
meeting Lor stro and see she goes after
drop ay at the Maya's house this is
where the idea of the Haunted House
comes in but we hear Michael's breathing
from behind the
door now one thing I only noticed on
this watch through is that when Lori
walks down the street we can see a car
in the driveway this seems like it's
pretty busted up and I was actually
wondering if this had a connection to
Michael with it being damaged and also
park there it isn't the one he stole but
I reached out to a couple of Halloween
YouTubers like Jimmy champagne and also
posted whether this was anything on
Twitter no one really knew anything
however if you know drop it in the
comments below though it might just be a
coincidence nowar start singing this
song I wish I had you all
along which was actually improvised on
the day but they made a full studio
version of it for the 2018 film
[Music]
[Applause]
gets played on the radio at one point
and is probably one of the nicest
callbacks to the original I will try and
stop talking about future sequels cuz
we're like three reboots deep uh but
this one was too good not to bring up
now the YouTube channel wolfman's gotot
nads he came up with a really
interesting theory about Michael
stalking Lori he actually thinks that
Michael may not have been after her and
instead he was only after her friends
and also their boyfriends looking at
this as a self-contained movie without
the sequel sister angle there's actually
a possibility that this is in fact the
case on the night he stalks Annie way
more than lri and tends to leave her
alone when the Sun goes down Lori ends
up going to the house by accident and
it's possible that she wasn't the
intended target that was going to spin
off in 50 follow-up films when we look
at the shrine this is dedicated to his
sister using Annie's body and Lori
wasn't really involved with an more
being the target I'll talk about more in
just a bit but though all the signs
leading up to the hospital talisis is
Illinois state they actually left a real
world indicator of where things really
were this happens when Lumis steps
outside with his colleague and we can
see there's a mat lying on the ground
this belongs to Lavina respiratory
Hospital in California showing where
these scenes were really shot at when
going to the car they also talk about
who taught Michael to drive haddenfield
is 150 M away from here now now for
God's sakes he can't drive a car he was
doing very well last night maybe someone
around here gave him lessons now for
years everyone's been like H how did the
kid learn to drive locked up in there
it's something I've seen countless
tweets and comments about every time the
subject of cause and Michael Myers has
brought up however if we look at the
novelization it actually offers some
answers written by Richard Curtis who
went another pen named Curtis Richard he
actually expanded on it and ended up
giving us an answer Richard said Michael
I actually watched Lumis closely when he
was driving him around from place to
place and picked it up by just staring
at what he was doing yep not lying and
all those times yeah you around with
your parents in the car mate you you
should have Bloody learned it too also I
I don't know if I'd be copying Lumis cuz
we can see he parked in the handicapped
spot and I checked the guy's Wikipedia
page and there's no need for him to park
like this you're taking the piss on top
of this there was also extra scene shot
at the mental institution when the movie
was getting adapted for TV during the
release of Halloween 2 Carpenter shot
some moments featuring a young Michael
that tied things more in with the sister
angle that they leaned into in the
sequels those scenes themselves were
briefly released on DVD but since that
imprint they've been completely cut out
that
was anyway in the classroom Lori sees
Michael staring at her which is
something that he's done ever since she
dropped the key off Tommy ends up
getting picked on by the bullies and we
also see as he's followed two one of the
kids runs into Michael and if you slow
down the footage you can actually see a
bit of his mask when the kid bumps into
him taking to the stay car this is a
vehicle that ends up popping up in the
background of scenes along with Michael
later on when it drives past Lori I love
how Carpenter kind of cuts around her
and we keep looking back to lorri like
her we're desperate to stare into the
car but this evad S as it starts to
speed away however if you pause the
footage and zoom in you can see him sat
there driving which is either terrifying
or absolutely hilarious now we also get
a moment where he hides behind the
bushes and over on the right hand ins
side you can actually see the car parked
up now from here we C Lumis making the
150 M drive to haddenfield which we were
told was the journey length when he was
at the hospital nice little detail here
is that we can see that the sign says
there 73 Mi left meaning that the man's
just made it past the halfway point here
he discovers a car Offroad which as we
can see belongs to Phelps garage this
explains how Michael got the mechanic
overalls and we get the mask explained
later on in the film although it's never
out and out said why he wears one it
does allow him to be further dehumanized
taking away his mask also takes away his
identity and thus he's someone we feel
even further detached from here Lumis
finds what looks like bed sheets again
which as we know was his inmate gown on
the ground he finds a box of matches
which he earlier looked at in Marian's
car before Michael stole it Sewell
pointed out that the rabbit on it could
be evoking sexual imagery because it
somewhat looks like the Playboy Bunny we
also have the red blood cover on it
which potentially for Shadows the
Bloodshed that's to come now back at the
school we see lockers outside which
again shows this was in Cali due to the
weather constantly being banging so I've
been told one day me and Philip Molina
will meet up I'll kill him I'll kill you
if you live in California kill them all
now this point we meet L's May with all
these Side characters possibly being
plays on production designer Tommy Lee
Wallace Tommy could be what inspired
Tommy doy with Lee potentially leading
into the name Lee bracket lastly is
Wallace going into Lee with he's all
having links directly to his name lri
also talks about how she forgot her
chemistry book and this is possibly
because she she doesn't have any sexual
chemistry however we can see as Linda
has a one love forever buck and she gets
killed with her boyfriend so hey I guess
it's true anyway Lori spots Michael
beating around the bush but we see as an
races over to see if someone's there
during this moment a little bit of smoke
passes by her head which was actually
from Carpenter chain smoking off screen
behind the camera now one thing you
might not notice about the film is how
subconsciously the spaces get smaller
and smaller we initially start off in
these wide streets but then things move
to houses before being confined to Rooms
come the end of it Lor's stuck in a
closet with it being an extremely
confined space that adds claustrophobia
it's a brilliant way to make us feel
like the walls are closing in with there
being less and less places to run as we
get further into to the film also if
there's a killer in the house mate don't
run upstairs yet more exits on the
ground and I'd appreciate the thumbs up
button for for just saving your life owe
me more more than that yeah but I
appreciate that also evil subscribes
tonight so if you're enjoying the video
please hit that subscribe button anyway
in Lor's room we see a hat up on the
wall which later returns in the 2018
sequel there also poster of a painting
by James Enzo who is famous for painting
people wearing masks now from we go to a
cemetery to see what happened at Judith
Maya's grave at this point we hear the
story yeah you know you know every town
is something like this
happen I remember over in Russellville
old charie bold about 15 years ago one
night he he finished dinner and he he
excused himself from the table and he
went out to the
garage he got himself a
hacksaw and then he went back into the
house and he kissed his wife and his two
children goodbye and then he proceeded
where are we huh oh uh it's h right over
here a Charlie featured in the short
story Halloween Charlie like a lot of
things in this movie though it was
actually based on a real story
discovered by reditus simple photograph
4216 they said they knew him and that he
ran a driving movie theater out in
Russellville Russellville was used his
home toown and about 30 minutes from
Bowling Green in Smith's Grove where
Corbin has spent most of his childhood
they went on to talk about how though
Charlie was no hack or murderer he was
involved in illegal activities like
bootlegging and gambling now this next
bit comes from Nightmare nostalgia.
comom and apparently when he was asked
about it Carpenter said the following he
is the father of an old girlfriend
deceased and at other things in his life
best left unsaid by me now this grave
being missing confirms till L miss that
Michaels come home and we then jump
across to see Annie and Lori being
stalked by him I love how he can see the
car creepily driving by behind them as
they move through the town and they also
Listen to Don't Fear the Reaper on the
radio foreshadowing the deaths that are
about to come smoking a joint we see
Lori coughing up and this shows that
she's not really into the lifestyle of
sex and drugs that her friends are at
this point we meet Sheriff Lee bracket
who would later return in some of the
sequels they're investigating a store
that Michael broke into and he says what
happened oh uh somebody broke into the
hardware store probably kids you blame
everything on kids all all they took was
some Halloween mask a rope and a couple
of knives this is of course what
Michael's been up to and it explains how
he got the mask Lumis ends up meeting
Lee and we can also see Michael driving
behind the peir however you can just see
him in the car checking the corners and
it cracks me up just just sitting there
I don't don't tell him I said this all
but it's just a very funny image at this
point Lori also says how she'd rather go
out with Ben trayer who's named after an
old friend of carpenter dick bter he'd
go out with you I'd rather go with Ben
trer followed Once More by the car again
I think the arguments there about him
stalking Annie as this is her car and in
the following scene he tells that while
sari gets dropped off getting out he
begins to stalk the house while hiding
behind a tree further giving the idea
that he was mainly after her in real
life you you wouldn't really work your
way up through targets until you got
your final girl you'd probably just go
after that one first cuz that's the one
you wanted most again we have a being
put just below Judith's grave showing
how she may have been the intended
target rather than it being Lori either
way that's
a and over at mea's house we hear do
anybody live here well not since 1963
when it happened every kid had feel
thinks this place is haunted actually
think there's something extra going on
with the house and other interpretations
of taking it down the direction that
there's more Supernatural things
involved this would be built upon the
year after in movies like AMD bille
horror and Carpenter did say he was
looking to create a horned House movie I
do find it interesting that the final
shut of the film is of the house and
there may be more going on with it than
what we're told initially up in the
bedroom they talk about where Judith
died and you could almost take this as
the house attacking
them also they do a ridiculous bit with
Lumis where he even plays into it to
scare off some kids chicken go ahead
Lonnie go in L get your ass away from
there now they find a de dog and Luma
says still
warm he got hungry probably the most
messed up bit in the entire film that
but no just glazed right over it Al
Lumis rattles off one of the most
unsettling monologues I've ever heard
and he describes Michael as a child I
spent 8 years trying to reach him and
then another seven trying to keep him
locked up because I realized that what
was living behind the that boy's eyes
was purely and simply evil this moment
is based on an experienced carbon a had
in college when he in his class were
taken to a psychiatric hospital he said
that he saw a child who just sted him
constantly and described them as having
luck of evil that terrified him with lri
we watch watches she starts slagging off
Comics laser
Man Neutron man I can understand why
tarantula man with tarantula man
obviously being a play on SP Spiderman
over with Annie the dog starts barking
too and we see Tommy looking out the
windows to see Michael standing in the
garden this was actually played by
Deborah Hill and along with Castle there
were several others in the suit when he
un masks later on this was an actor
named Tony Moran who was further picked
for his Angelic features killing the dog
outside we see it dropping down and
going limp which was actually achieved
by just slowing down the footage so it
seemed to lose all life on the TV we see
the thing from another world starting
and Carpenter would later go on to
direct the thing in 1982 I'm sure you've
heard that a thousand times before but
it's a nice little detail now we know
where Carpenter's career took him Tommy
constantly keeps asking about the
buggyman and this of course becomes
something lri later describes Michael as
I feel like his Legend is kind of based
around the idea of a creature coming
back every Halloween and it just keeps
Mayas is a dark figure that makes him
seem more like a personification of evil
and he gets locked in the ouse and I
love how you can kind of see Michael
moving around in the glass behind her as
she tries to pull open the door back in
the house she ends up answering the
phone and we can also see him standing
in the doorway as she crosses the
kitchen as she starts back towards the
door we can also see Michael's Shadow
disappearing as he quickly shuffles off
cuz doesn't like being on camera now
back in the living room we see Lindsay
watching TV and can hear forbidden
planets about to go into a commercial
turn off the lights don't go away cuz
here's a scene great bit of attention to
detail as they then leave the house and
cross the street which is when they
arrive at Tommy's the movie's just
starting up again after the break which
I think is a brilliant bit of continuity
how do you like that
kitty I'm in here and now the horrifying
conclusion to Big shout out to Matt Goa
for pointing that out and Lori later
tells Tommy and Lindsay to run to the
McKenzie in Scream Casey Becka's dad
tells her to go to the McKenzie which
comes full circleing H2O and Lori says
go to the Beckers yay we live in a
little murder town anyway Annie ends up
leaving lindsy with her but we know
Michael was stalking her as he was
behind the car just before she reached
the house and he's then killed with this
sort of being a first real look at
Michael but it's obscured by the misted
up glass back with Tommy and Lindsay we
can also see a how the duck comic which
was title repercussions not sure if
there's a deeper meaning to it but it
was released June that year which hints
to when the movie was actually shot now
we see Michael carrying Annie into the
house and at this point the murder spree
continues Linda and her boyfriend are
killed with Michael impaling the ladder
against the wall it's such a memorable
moment Michael later goes to Linda
wearing his glasses in the sheet which I
always took his Carpenter kind of acting
like this was his newly created ghost
the boyfriend going downstairs could
somewhat Echo his sister too who went
downstairs only this time Michael caught
him you really get the idea that he's
fascinated with death as he even stands
and tilts his head looking at the body
almost like a confused puppy it adds his
feeling that he's still the innocent
child in there who's never really
changed since that first Halloween night
now the idea of sex fascinating Michael
could even potentially be tighten with
the screams his victims make which
potentially also sound like the screams
of getting it on back at the Myers Lumis
recognizes the sanitarium car and then
Lori makes her way over to the house
where Michael's located at after finding
the bodies we see she runs to a room and
Michael's head slowly starts to appear
out the darkness this was achieved
pretty easily with them using a small
Dem switch that they brought up to
illuminate The Mask running through the
streets we see as Michael slowly stalks
her and it's a slow movement that makes
him so terrifying lots of villainous
characters take this on to be more
intimidating because it shows they don't
need to run in order to catch their
target it's semat been used with a lot
of horror villains with the way the
Terminator portrayed in that first film
being my personal favorite Michael gets
in and tries to stab Lori but she Jabs
him in the neck and this later leaves a
Mark that we see in the 2018 recel even
though Lori thinks she killed him he
ends up returning which is when we get
that Infamous cupbo scene no idea why
she did this and apparently Jam Lee
Curtis also gets asked all the time why
she didn't hold on to the knife still
she takes him out with a Cod hanger but
he rises once more almost like a zombie
coming back from the dead making him
Unstoppable just so much to the movie
and I feel this is why he's such an
iconic villain eventually he's unmasked
and we see his true face and can catch's
being struck in the eye which Lori did
before Lumis ends up shooting him over
the balcony however his body's nowhere
to be seen and Lori says what's the
Boogey
Mir according to IMDb trivia her right
cheek is noticeable lines in it and this
is because just before the scene was
shot jimie had fallen asleep on a couch
downstairs which put an impression on
her face
we then close out with Michael's
breathing over the top of shots of the
houses and streets Lumis originally was
going to be surprised at his Escape but
instead Pleasant suggested that he had a
Lu that he knew this was going to happen
in the end they shot both with
Pleasant's version being the one that
they used in the film this implies
Michael is out there and he could be
anywhere down any Street lots of
podcasts I listen to like now playing
they talked about how there was this
real fear at the time once people went
home that Michael could be out there he
was never caught and was still living at
large leading to a feeling of an ease
upon exiting the cinema I feel like
these scenes are almost shot like a
documentary with them showcasing America
and the evil that's been Unleashed on it
for reasons like this Michaels remained
in the public Consciousness for decades
and even now they're still trying to
recapture the feeling people had
watching the first film now this
documentary style is present throughout
the movie with Carpenter scaling back on
the goal as much as he could this was
further building off the back of stuff
like psycho in which the violence was
toned down so the audience's imagination
did the work I think it really is
another thing that makes this movie
Stand Out as we create the violence in
the film rather than witnessing it now I
hope you've enjoyed our track back
through Halloween and obviously if
there's anything we miss then please
drop it below and I always get comments
like this is all being said before you
you rubbish but it's it's it's difficult
trying to find 30 minutes worth of new
details in a movies that's almost 50
years old mate what I try and do though
is I just pile everything together sort
of make the best definitive collection
of trivia I can and I hope you enjoyed
as always shout out to sources who
helped out this video like seworld Jimmy
champagne Wolfman now playing and yeah
there's so many people out there who
contributed to every little bit of this
film being picked apart now I did
discover that chatner actually found out
about the mask using his likeness and
that he ended up trying to Super past
royalties he donated this to charity but
apparently the case could have been
dismissed easily as he doesn't even own
the rights to Captain Kirk now that poll
we talked about at the start of the
video as well that had the ring coming
second place and I I treated myself to
the ring goo and also the the ring
collection so we will be covering that
in just one big breakdown we'll be doing
that next time with it hopefully
dropping just before Halloween but it
just depends how schedules are as
there's a lot of things in October
anyway if you want to listen to those
videos early then please click The Joint
button we drop the audio for members as
soon as that's finished and then follow
up with the video Once that's been
edited means you can listen to it like a
podcast to watch it when we have it
ready and it massively helps support the
channel for less than a dollar or a
pound a month if not then thank you for
your support anyway I know times are
tough I don't blame you H but if you
could leave a thumbs up that would that
would be a really good way to help us
out for free and it makes a massive
difference now if you want to see
another carpender classic being broken
down then please check out our recent
thing one on screen right now talk about
lots of little things in the film we
debunk the kerosene Theory once and for
all so and we we just talk about how
much we love that movie because it it's
absolutely fantastic now without the way
huge thank you for clicking the video
hopefully my voice hasn't been too bad
and I hopefully also see you on the next
one by the way you take care of yourself
enjoy Halloween and yeah have the best
month possible peace